the gentleman at the very far end of our
guest row you've enjoyed him in movies
like Straight Outta Compton and
Christmas movie sequel die hard with a
vengeance he was in that Christmas movie
sequel oh don't worry
Rothman we're gonna get to that with all
this Hodge in this conversation at some
point on and and Friday Night Lights in
which I also enjoyed your work good to
see you back here on the show Aldous
Hodge and the man to your left in
between the two of us is a guy who I got
to meet at our podcast days back in the
day at the NFL Network well several
years ago when he had just finally
gotten clear of being falsely accused of
rape trying to get into football once
again after being falsely accused and
having a promising football
uprize cut short good to see you Brian
banks and all this you play Brian banks
in the new film Brian banks says that's
about to open right here in the LA Film
Festival so good to see both you guys
here so before we get into this Aldous
with you about playing Brian Brian I
want to give you the floor for folks who
may not know your story you're from here
in Long Beach in California and you you
were you verbally committed to UIC is
that where I had verbally committed to
USC linebacker you plays linebacker I
was eleven eleven in the nation at the
end of my junior year peak era was a
head coach at the time over at USC and
we developed a good relationship a good
friendship and I had all the intentions
in the world after my senior year to
move on to playing ball with the Trojans
just like Willie McGinest from your
school look after Willie
Willie's a legend in our city right you
know watching him come out of the same
program the same system and to make it
on to the league it was let me be honest
by inspiring yeah and then what happened
Shh the least expected I went to a known
area on my high school campus was a
known makeout spot I went with the girl
that I've known since middle school we
made out we didn't have sex but by the
end of that day I was being arrested and
accused of rape the same day that I was
arrested was the same day that
everything began and and I did not come
home until five years later at the age
of 22 after serving 85% of a six-year
sentence
for for rape conviction which then was
followed by an additional five years on
strict custody parole as a registered
sex offender can live within 2,000 feet
of any school or Park I did
he was impossible to find work there was
really no social life there at all for
ten years in my life I lived the life of
a convicted sex offender and all for it
to come to an end when this this girl
came forward they made as she lied about
everything why did she lie about
everything you know to this day we still
don't know what started to lie I can
only make an assumption in my assumption
after these after all the years that had
passed by is that maybe she didn't want
me to go back to my friends to announce
what we just did I had a fear that it
would embarrass her make her look a
certain type of way and so she went on
to beat me to that by saying she was
forced into doing it that's the only
thing I can that's my guess because
she's never taken full responsibility
for the lie
she's always point two finger at other
people it started off as a small lie and
because other people got involved they
grew bigger bigger and bigger bigger
bigger so you know it's funny and she
said there's a scene in a movie actually
where the district attorney asked me
that same question why would she lie and
you know the response was I you know I
don't really think it's my
responsibility to answer the question
for her you know it we still don't know
and all this one's you first hear about
the Brian banks story it's weird man
because when it came out I definitely
heard about it sure was a 12 13 2013 12
yeah I think that I kind of start
hearing about it and yes I can somebody
messed up and then movie comes around
I'm like this sounds really familiar
yeah you know I started doing the
research and I said oh wait a minute
yeah I heard about this of course just
because of
how unfair was you know it's why I kind
of stuck in my brain because you look at
all of the facts there you say somebody
who was sleeping at the wheel there's a
lot of people not doing their job
because nobody's checking or looking out
for him well is this the legal system
obviously is a complex and fickle system
and I know those are two words that I'm
sure would have stronger words for that
Bryant but you took a plea deal what
what happened you know with that so it's
a it was a situation where I had been
incarcerated for nine months fight in
this case and was about to select a jury
to go to trial I was facing 41 years to
life tried as an adult at the age of 16
and my lawyer beat me to an interview
room before going into the courtroom and
said I just came up with this amazing
deal with the district attorney's office
this deal you must take they had already
offered me 25 years in prison 18 years
in prison nine years in prison but there
was no DNA and if evidence there was no
DNA evidence there was no physical
evidence there was no witnesses she has
six different statements and testimony
as to what happened everything was in my
favorite it should have been a walk on a
court and as easy dismissal but because
I had an adequate counsel I was pretty
much forced into taking a plea which I
thought would have gotten me probation
it turned out to be six years in prison
and I had to serve 85% of that time I
did five years in two months of that
time all because of the the assurance
from my then attorney this would all be
figured out you'll be ok we'll we'll get
this cleared you won't see any prison
time but if you go in that courtroom as
a big black teenager they will see you
guilty you know you're you look at you
this was the advice that I was given at
the age of 17 and had already been
incarcerated for a year and I'm sitting
here contemplating literally given ten
minutes to make this decision do I walk
into this courtroom and select a jury
risk my entire life in prison for
something I didn't do or do I walk into
this courtroom and take a deal play out
a crime that I didn't even commit you
know I realized in that moment after you
no fight in this case for that long that
I wasn't going home Brian banks here
Brian banks story again Brian banks in
the LA Film Festival this Saturday and
then the eventual theater near you for
this film coming in all dis Holling you
Brian in this film so what was it like
playing Brian in this film because
eventually it it starts with you being
on parole correct that this film starts
okay and so what was it like for you
playing Brian from this talk about
emotionally intense man it was I said
was a really beautiful and fortuitous
experience because it helps you just put
a lot of things in perspective and
understand humility and being grateful
the whole time we were working like
Brian and I began our relationship about
a month and a half maybe two months
before we even got to set because we
started in the gym I was looking for
training because I had to get my weight
up you know I was trying on my own but
I'll say hey you know I called a brown
what'd you do and then I was like wait a
minute well you know and that's where we
started our fellowship and my
Brotherhood and I got to learn who he
was as a person which was really great
because you know as I said before you
you learn a lot about a person when you
see how they deal with pain and in the
gym we're dealing with physical pain and
there's a mentality of don't worry about
it get through it go beyond and then you
start understanding how he can deal with
the mental and spiritual pain of being
left alone being dealing with the the
shame of knowing that you're innocent
when everybody else says that you're
wrong and you're treated as as such but
it gave me such a breath of fresh air
one artistically because as an actor you
know I want to fill my life with
meaningful work and this is some of the
proudest work I've ever done in my
30-year career
in fact the proudest role that I feel
like I've taken on not only because I
feel like I get to learn well I get to
share what I've learned and hopefully
and inform other people but I do hope
that I will help in honoring your life
we
because you know I feel like he's a
martyr he went through what he went
through
but how rare is it to go through all
that you know carcere 89 months five
years in prison five years you know on
parole and then come out to clear your
own name you actually make it to the NFL
you know you work for the NFL you live
the dream and now you have a movie being
made about your life there's a reason
for all that that's it's all it's
there's a pattern to it it's all lay it
out and there's a reason for it and he
chose to take his situation not let it
on him and use it for what it was
intended for which is to teach and
hopefully make things better for other
people so they can realize that there's
still problems in the world and we're
hopefully trying to be a part of the
solution so it was a really a fantastic
experience outside of just the the
satisfaction of having a great role as
an actor it helped educate me on life a
little bit more as a man well said
that's incredible and so Pete Carroll
was interestingly enough one of the
first guys to give you a shot to try out
in the NFL the day that I was exonerated
may 24 2012 we'll walk out of a
courtroom right in front of a sea of
reporters and one of the first questions
was now that you're free what are you
gonna do with this freedom and I looked
in the camera I said I've been training
for this shot at the Internet do you
know Phil if there's any team out there
that wants to give me a shot you give me
a call I guarantee you I will outwork
anybody on your team and the following
day my phone rang and there was a
brother at the other hand going up yeah
I'm looking for a linebacker you know
where I can find one I said what do you
got the right number this is me man
speaker
he called it yeah he called me right
away and it was like it was crazy it was
like that recruiting dance all over
again from here we are in high school in
college now you know exoneree and an NFL
coach and he kept trill he's on the
phone he said look be I'm gonna be
honest you've been out the game ten
years you probably can't do Sh Yeah
right yeah but uh you know I love your
story and what you've been through and
what you've persevered through and I
remember you back in you know back in
the high school days you're a great
player I love to give me an opportunity
and luckily I had been training for this
opportunity when I tried out for Seattle
got invited back to training camp ended
I'm not making it needed some more you
know rediscovery on the the knowledge
side of the game and eventually worked
my way through a few tryouts and signing
with the Falcons mm-hm what was that
like for you being on an NFL gridiron
after all you'd been through Brian you
know it's funny because having missed my
opportunity at the time that I was
supposed to mates make it to the league
and then going as a 28 year old rookie
it was kind of an experience it was kind
of an experience I felt like even though
maybe I should not be experiencing this
wow wow because it was so it was a dream
that was taken away it was something I
went and reached back for right but at
the same time it was kind of like going
back into my own past to relive a dream
that I never got to relive and so as I
was living in and I'm running out into
the field and the flames are going up in
the smoke and the crowd is going crazy
my mom's and the stands crying it took
me back I felt like I was that young 16
year old boy I was taken off the streets
again and it was kind of like I got a
chance to take a little piece from a
history that I didn't get a chance to
live and in a ways it's something I will
never forget I'll always take it with me
I'll always remember it the four games
that I played
was my my Super Bowl was my you know my
my trophy my it was everything
it was everything and to see my mom you
know happy and in pleasant and and free
of worry in those moments I'll never
forget it I'll never forget it
and this is something that uh I can't
experience and then walk away and keep
it to myself I got to share through this
film as well so what do you what would
you want people to take away then Brian
from your story through all this is you
know acting and through this film
through your whole story will you want
people to take away from that we have a
system a judicial system that's not
perfect that has flaws like anything
else that we need to restore and develop
moral and ethical obligations into our
judicial system furthermore that we're
gonna go through things in life that are
our that are of the unwanted things that
we didn't know we were going to
experience things that we don't want to
experience but it's not what you go
through but how you allow it to affect
you what you choose to do moving forward
you know I always tell people one of the
first things I share with him when we
first met I shook his hand I said look
at me don't judge me by what I've been
through
judge me by how I dealt with it because
therein lies true character you know so
for me I had to I had to wake up one day
in a very dark place and remind myself
that I didn't have to travel far to find
the like I was the light in a very dark
place and it took like anything mastered
it took time in practice but eventually
I made my way out of a dark hole but
furthermore turn right back around and
reach my hand in there to pull out the
next person and I think that that's what
this story does this movie is going to
show and portray is the the the the
spirit of resiliency to never give up to
never quit but to also want to see other
people be treated as they should be
fairly and accordingly and that starts
with changing hopefully laws and
policies within our judicial system do
you think the NFL players that are
taking a moment social activism or
locking arms raising fists and or taking
any or doing so for part in you Brian
what rephrase that question you think
that what they are protesting against in
the NFL is in part representing you well
III think that I think that the protest
has been has been established that it's
about police brutality the unfairness
and how people of color are being
treated by the police departments across
the nation I think that this story what
this is going to focus on is subjects
such as how people of color are
treated and and in dealt with in our
legal process and our legal systems well
Doug Baldwin is and along with Malcolm
Jenkins are both in just two separate
parts of the country now going into
state houses talking about this very
issue yeah Doug Baldwin connected with
the Attorney General of the state of
Washington on yeah these very and it's
it's an issue that that we should be
doing a lot more than for you know you
think about 95 to 97 percent of all
criminal cases in the u.s. ends in some
form of a plea bargain only 3 to 5
percent of people will actually see
trial that means you're being forced
into deals feared into deals exhausted
into deals I was a juvenile Treisman
tried as an adult so there's a lot of
different components and things within
our system Det
when you think about it yes race does
have become a part in it because a lot
of these people who are experiencing are
people of color and people of color but
African Americans we make up 16% of the
u.s. population but make up over 60% of
our incarceration population so when you
look at those numbers it kind of answers
itself and at Bryan bank's free on
Twitter I follow you seeing with you all
at Aldous Hodge go check out again if
you're in Los Angeles Brian banks
premiering at the LA Film Festival this
Saturday and keep an eye peeled for when
it comes to a town near you great to see
you Brian banks it really is it's a
pleasure to say I guess I I know you oh
really one day I could run that 40 next
to you by the way I I would love to see
that I'd love to see actually I'll
probably be seeing it from behind you
okay that's Aldous Hodge in Brian banks
right here on the Rich Eisen show
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience